so you know these are city planners who
built to last I mean downtown Turin has
about a Megaton of these surviving four
hundred year old baroque buildings are
very hard to destroy they're mostly
brick because brick absorbs cannon fire
but there's some marble and even by
military standards these are some
alarmingly stout urban structures and
some of them get abandoned for a hundred
years or more they don't fall down they
don't rot they don't collapse
they just silently endure they're like
Egyptian pyramids and eventually people
show up again and they tend to just loft
them out so you know now they're all
over the place and they're not
aristocratic buildings of course they're
museums archives hospitals cultural
centers grocery stores tourist
attractions futuristic planned palaces
that just won't go away
I mean they just don't wear out that's
why their futuristic it has been there
all the time and I have one of my own
now so you know in my bag here I've got
some postcards of my pet tourney's 375
you're all palace oh yeah Thank You
Stuart yes that's that that's our latest
tourney's renewal project the Phoenix
renewed so we're trying to find a new
tenant who will move into this palace
and renovate this palace and then this
tenant needs to stay there for about 60
years they're trying to find a guy with
some staying power and you know it'll
take about a hundred and 50 grand to
maintain the palace and it's Gardens
which are very extensive it's like four
stories high and it basically has about
the same square cubic meter egde as your
odd building here I mean you're you're
in a stuffed animal building of some
kind you know and this is a similar
thing you mean it's a big it's got the
volume of your thing you're it's just
that it's it's it's baroque in its 17th
century and it's got like paintings and
statuary and chandeliers and carpets and
that's our writer office so you know we
were done with our house of the future
project and our in our fact
when we got this call from the local
Cultural Foundation who were called the
company of st. Paul the Campania to San
Paolo and they're a non-governmental
Enterprise in Turin an NGO and they're
500 years old I really they've been
around half a millennium so these guys
are running this 500 year old charity
and they happen to be fans of ours it
turns out they really like to read
science fiction so they asked us you
know if we would leave our house the
future and we would do a video to
advertise one of their palaces to
attract possible new tenants because
they managed this brick palace which is
up in the hills and it's called the
delightful vineyard of the Royal madam
you know the vineyard madam oh really
and it's a place with a rather checkered
history so it turns out that this palace
of this villa our new office was built
by and for a guy who was one of my
favourite torinese historical characters
I didn't realize it was actually his
palace until we'd like moved into the
place but I considered him a kind of
ultimate torinese historical character I
know a lot about him it's a super
interesting guy to me I just never
expected that he would become my
landlord so we know we went into this
baroque Palace and they gave us the
formal tour of the entire thing top to
bottom so he went up the attic which is
this amazing looking crooked Garret we
said wow what a fantastic office for
creative writers and actually the entire
building was a historical archive that
was its most recent use mostly it was
stuffed full of 500 years of financial
records centuries of them just all over
the place financial banking records but
it was empty because the archivist had
digitized the records and they'd like
left the place
so it was record free and now and they
are looking for a new tenant so we
volunteered I mean we moved in and we
don't reside in our palace and we
certainly can't afford it there are no
bedrooms in there but when we're in our
when we're in Turin we commute to our
Palace at 9 a.m. and we go up to the
attic we plug in the old computers and
we have at some creative writing and the
palace and then we leave promptly at
5:00 because they
lock the whole place up electronically
and we go back to our actual apartment
which is a completely different area of
Turin we don't rent the palace we don't
pay us to be there just kind of a
friendly understanding we're just
residents in the palace I'm the
visionary and residents at the villa are
big and you know we write novels about
turin and except for one security guard
board guy downstairs reading sci-fi
novels we are the only people and this
huge ancient building I mean we're just
like the modern ghosts and this 375 year
old structure it's just us and that
statuary and the priceless paintings in
the chandeliers and the giant carpets
and the many other relics and the huge
weedy garden and the secret tunnels and
the weird lake with the Opera set on a
little island and a greenhouse and big
urns that are like shrouded in ivy and
it's not a house of the future but it is
our Palace of the past and when we're
not around we really kind of miss it
it's surprising how quickly you can get
used to palatial surroundings so you
know I know this sounds rather comic
noises the sci-fi writer is marooned
inside the ancient palace no it's like
an it'll oh Calvino story right it's
just it's oxymoronic and now it's got a
lot of like trick reversal kind of stuff
going on but it is certainly the
weirdest thing that ever happened to me
in Turin right and it has it has some
element of karmic retribution right so
it's like you're a guy you're a futurist
and you claim to be outside of time I
mean you have some some higher
understanding of historic processes and
and you even have the power to do weird
things and empty factories because you
can like convince people to help you but
that car Factory is merely 100 years old
you should try some of your cheap
futurist magic tricks with this other
building from another pace layer
entirely 375 years old UNESCO World
Heritage Age
[Music]